más militares en las calles de colombia
especialmente en la ciudad de cali donde
perdieron la vida 13 personas
precisamente el día que se cumplía un
mes de protestas contra el gobierno de
iván duque es un día fatídico es un día
doloroso y es un día que ha significado
muerte en nuestro territorio y en
nuestro espacio todavía no podemos
precisar si todas las muertes que hemos
tenido durante el 28 de mayo están
vinculadas y asociadas integralmente al
proceso de la protesta la respuesta del
presidente duque fue militarizar todavía
más la ciudad epicentro de las protestas
donde ya hay siete mil soldados el
mandatario anunció el máximo despliegue
permitido por la figura de la asistencia
militar una ley que sólo puede usarse en
situaciones excepcionales de manera
temporal y que conlleva que el ejército
apoye la policía en tareas de control y
de seguridad
tú que toma una decisión parecida para
el departamento del cauca y su capital
popayán una ciudad a unos 150 kilómetros
al sur de cali que durante las últimas
semanas también ha vivido protestas el
28 de mayo por ejemplo terminaron con el
incendio de la alcaldía hemos abierto el
camino a darle cabida plena a esa
asistencia militar en la ciudad de
popayán y en el departamento para la
ciudad de popayán va haber un aumento
del 25 por ciento en el pie de fuerza
del ejército para acompañar la
asistencia militar
tras un mes de manifestaciones que
acumulan decenas de muertes y
desaparecidos entre otras denuncias de
violencia policial el representante del
secretario general de la onu en colombia
pidió recurrir al diálogo y no a la
violencia un llamado al que se unió la
organización de estados américanos